.
THATHT REPUBLICAN --LDING BACK,T
ADAM KINA
TONIGHT.U BOTH FOR
OM
ENT BIDEN.
HE'S IHE'S
ATTEMPTINGRAACK
VOTERS AS HE'S BSING
HELPED COMPIMO THE
NOMINATION.
WHE SUPR TOWARD THEISTY
PREDE
TODA
TIME, THEY'RE STILL
THE COS.
WE ALL NEED TO RISE TO MEEEMONO.
BELLION WASU MAKE OF HIM
BYIN FALLY
ACTUALLY PRETT.IT WASN'T A E  OF
OF USHA THEY'RE NURSE AND YOU
KNOW THAT KIND OF, WE HAVE THISK
A OIT'SE
T BIDEN ISAYS WERE AT,W YOU'VE T
THE 'THETWATH AND THE VIONC
ELECTION.NUA6TH AND E  COULD CE
FOR,E I THINK HE'S DOING A
GOODOB TRYING TO GET BACS HOME ,
REMINDING TH O OUFF THAT MAYEOFG
WHAT WE'RE SEEING AS PLONG TRADY
NGS POLITICS IN AMERICA.
CGROMES AS AT LEAST- RCONFCE CS
NOW ECHOINT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS USING
WHEN IT MEDETHWENT TO E CAPITALE
THAT DAY, DESCRIBING TM
HOSTAGES.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID --
HAVE CONCERNS ATMT OF JANRYHOS.
CONCERNS, WE HAVE A ROLE
IN CONGRESS OF OVERSIGHTOUR TRE
WEAPONIZATION OF THEL GOVERNMET
JUST PRENT ICONS
CO SEEING CH
MEMBER OF YOURYING THAT?
>> WELL, ELISE IS SO IREYRS VICD
P SAYSHENOS
WATCHING, SHE'S PROBABLY
G R TAX TOLD OR GOOD
JOB.
SHE FELT REA
SH
S --
STILOUSET.KIN FILE MARHOW,
--
DONALD TRUMP, I DON'TNOYSI'M N.
E LEF
.
WHAT Y REPUBLICAN,
ER UP
--
NOYIH JANUARXSTAGES.
HERE'S WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE.
OVER A OAS IT MEA
LIMIT TESTTHER YREEG N,
WHETHER YOU SAHOSTAGES OR
PRISONERS.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ME  PEOPLS.
DO THINK 'S SVIS
JUST, ONE OF THE AREASNK
AS WEL JEN --
PERSON WHO'SOINGD THINCAUSE HEEH
STRONG.
REALITY IS HE'S A WHINER.
DOING THIS BECAUSHE'S A
VICTIM'S OWN MIND, AND HE WASTOE
DONALD TRUMP IS A VERYEA
WAY TOO AMAGE IN THIS
SPAC EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOTNECESSR